you
everyone is Jerry Amman leeches org and
I am playing a 15-10 game
just got paired up against you chess
okay
let's go with c4
not by fur
against you chess probably the first
time though for standard alright let's
start with Knight c3
Grunfeld or not
felt it is
okay this can turn sharp quickly
I'm considering Bishop to g5
this is the move I've played in the past
other moves include Knight f3 captures
think even III is available
okay I'm gonna give this a go
ninety-five
a bishop backup Knight takes pawn takes
takes and black is up upon in May
actually hang on to it so we'll see if I
could play e3 and conveniently recapture
with my bishop I'd be happy about that
this isn't something that black should
allow so reinforcing this point after e3
I like my position quite a lot I think
the the real test is to chop away give
up the pawn but give up the center pawn
for black and go from there
believe I've had this position as white
against
hmm in the Blitz game against a
Vladislav Artemyev
I don't think it went so well in that
game there was a Bishop e6 move
okay so what
considering here
for
on maybe e for another is to maybe just
play Knight f3 this pawn is in a pin
and this is a manoeuvre to maybe try and
hunt that pawn let's start with
you have three I don't think there's a
better Square for it so let's go with
this least flexible move first this pawn
has more flexibility than the night
maybe I squeeze a little bit more out of
this guy playing to e4 instead of e3
I don't know if I want to do this
because I'm anticipating some pressure
against in d4 c5 Bishop g7 so
reinforcing d4 has its points
what games have we played 501 Oh 100k
you
well
what other move besides moving the epon
oh actually
can I not try and pick up the pawn
straightaway
in fact if I really wanted to
I've done it here
guess so let me revisit or let's a look
at it for the first time really clean a
four check what is blacks reply
check
maybe ec6 if let's see sex though here
c6 threatening this but Queen a for c6
Queen takes pawn Bishop e6 Queen d3
I really don't see anything wrong with
scooping this pawn up
I mean what I what I would love to do is
this and this but like won't let me
scoop that pawn up so easily so
conveniently I would much rather pick
that pawn up with the bishop but I don't
think that will be allowed
b5 Bishop e6
okay well let's go for a variation I
haven't gone for before in this line the
simple recapture of the palm get the
material back
so my I'm hesitant to do this because I
I feel my queen will be subjected to
some attack bishop possibly maybe even
the night after I recaptured on c3
this square the square both are holes
this one here is more accessible to the
black piece as you can see something
like this a coordinated piece is
coordinating on c4 Knight to d7 now I do
not have to take here just yet hmm
this pawn is still pinned this Knight is
pinned
absolute pin
if I play this
hmm you know
maybe I just go with III
III just to reinforce this point maybe I
can get away with taking on c4 with a
bishop even
if a six I could still take with the
Bishop b5 I can take because there's a
pin I don't think I want to get
aggressive with the e pun in fact I
think once castled and out of this pin I
don't want to have to tend to Knight
takes pawn I could maybe go at a later
stage e4
but for now I'll just stick with e3
so candidate
for black if black plays c6 I cannot
take because b5 is there a six is just
imaginary defense of b5 because of the
pin c6 is a different story so on c6 on
pins the knight prepares b5 or even
Knight to be six so on c6 I'll be taking
on c4 with the queen as otherwise I
don't think I'm getting the pound back
you know these kind of moves
really reinforce c4 it's not going
anywhere
and this undermining stuff isn't there
in time
okay
one thing that did cross my mind instead
of III I didn't share yet was to maybe
interfere with castles pinpoint a7
okay
no there's this and in a candidate I
should not have allow my opponent to
pick up the bishop here so easily
okay
this pawn is still pinned so this
is the one way to strike at the palm
probably the correct way forward had to
guess
see five
do not think I will be capturing
I'm underdeveloped I still - moves out
castling
you
Knight b6 I could consider one of these
two I mean one of these two moves has to
come for Black as otherwise if I
complete development here here
everything is wonderful Bishop outside
the pawn chain Knight rests on a good
square Bishop is on a good square and I
could look forward to maybe throwing the
a pawn up applying some pressure on the
Queen side along the B file so I think
it's a position black is in a position
where timing is very important as to
strike fast and I mean
I think c5 in Queen 85 have to come
actually c5 with the idea to take and
then Queen a5 and at least be disruptive
to these next two moves so yeah
c5 it is
okay
well how do i Perry
this idea because here takes takes Queen
a5 I have to go here
or castle by hand okay I'm gonna try to
find a convenient way to go about things
if I try to
Queen a5
I think I may be running into this even
so maybe it's the way forward is
allowing the Queen to get to 85 to
strong rook c1 take take check clean
block
I don't mind a clean exchange there
maybe I do
I mean you could take a pond but I don't
know if I really fear that so much in
that position I'd be fearing let's say
Brooke c1
taketake Queen a5 Queen c3 Queen takes
rook takes and then II five there's no
longer this pin my sinners coming under
fire the position is opening up I'm
still behind with getting my King Castle
too even though the Queen's are off the
board I don't like that the position is
yeah files and diagonals are opening up
do I have to do this might be six I'm
not really too concerned about
well in here's another thing why am I
thinking I have to take with the c-pawn
in general taking towards the center
right but suppose Bishop e2 takes and I
take with this pawn end up with hanging
pawn structure
one
rook ad1 take take clean here up d2
into a pin doesn't seem right night here
looking to take advantage of that pin
Queeny for he's six I really want to be
able to take like this
you
chewing up a lot of time here
have to just take with this pawn after
see tasty for
sure what else
this is the correct the move orders
important Queen a5i castle takes takes
takes first here and then
clean a5 move I should revisit this here
check can i really get away with
you're alright with that now not really
a fan of that
it's possible hmm
okay so I think I'm going to end up
playing with a hanging pawn structure it
may be challenged and soon maybe I'll
have an isolated pawn but that isolated
pawn will be passed so tough to say
whether or not it'll be a liability or
an asset
usually not a fan of playing with an
isolated pawn I could see black in this
case coordinating well on d5 the square
right in front so let's say here here
Queen a5 castles here and after an
exchange of epon and my C pawn and
blacks a pawn there you go I'd end up
with an isolated D pawn
so these
can all be exchanged basically and I'm
left with that guy
surprising surprised not to see Queen
extremely surprised not to see this
capture right now this would drop up
home so
I mean here I'm not even thinking about
maybe I could think about that but I
want what other what other movies black
considering here a little bit surprised
I feel like you gotta go with this
I'm here trying for e5 I think this
should be on board
all right well we've both gone into the
tank early here 11 moves oh there we go
right so this starts to make a whole lot
of sense
coordinating on c4 especially now that
I'm working with these two now one thing
that I do like is that I have a queen
reply that does throw a punch right back
nice Evan so Knight b6 Queen c5 Knight
b6 Queen B for I'm thinking Queen c5
it's definitely getting sharp McQueen
move
No
this guy's probably a bit uncomfortable
to block
yeah that would be I was black I'd be
thinking this guy is a pest at least a
little bit one piece exerting pressure
on blacks side
something other than might be sex may be
trying to Fein keto this has its points
to not only get developed but also form
a grip oversee for a six and A four is
not a defense against to be five because
my work is unprotected
so a six a 4 B 5 takes takes no time to
take back because my rook
and rook takes rook I'm not on the Queen
so a six what what I do probably just
Castle a move I cannot do without and
wait to see maybe uh and reply to be
five I could be a little bit annoying
okay
hmm okay well think it's time to cancel
let's go
this starts to
be pretty appealing
[Music]
okay
some interesting moves here here here
come to mind clean before I think
that'll be met with this hmm
yeah prefer blacks position here see
this is a liability should I play this
anticipating a rook c8 in my queen Theo
somewhere else and not have to defend
here I'm gonna say I'm gonna go with
this first
fc8 maybe this or this
thinking maybe this kind
touching at that point
think I am threatening to take Queen
won't be trapped I'm on the bishop at
the end here here and then I am
threatening to take
you
what is black considering
Knight f6 comes to mind
this I'd have six maybe I back up and
I'm prepared to maybe play c4 Bishop can
be unpredictable
tected right I don't see how you take
advantage of it just yet though
here here whoops unprotected peace
this move were threatened
but that's just a poor decision okay
Queen
[Music]
isn't that a blunder if I take if I take
and then take here
I lose out because the unprotected
pieces however
I take here right now and then rook here
I could move my bishop away it's a big
bone
this guy would become
let me calculate here Bishop take c7 I
guess it's true that if
here and then I back up with my bishop
Bishop takes Knight I I could exchange
first something up here what am I
missing
here here
I don't know I think I just back up with
my bishop
think maybe was only what was calculated
was a queen exchange and then I couldn't
do this
uh here first I think is a pawn
you
yeah
you
here I'm out of the line
fire yeah I think it was just I think it
was the only considered first the Queen
exchange and then this capture
forgetting that I'm still here now this
here rook takes Bishop Queen takes
bishop here doesn't win the material
back as I have c4
and the the fact that there
an immediate reply makes me think that
it that this was in fact a mistake Queen
the c8 so this is a backward pawn but
I'm up and I am up upon and this one is
past where to go with my bishop here
gorgeous
maybe even here's an idea
and I like this I think
[Music]
you
I'm gonna go all the way back
you
so takes takes Bishop takes Knight still
up upon Bishop hair
structure but that shouldn't be
compensation there's even
this can be an annoying pin if there's
the bishop for night exchange under
three
you
maybe this it's not gonna be easy for me
I mean that black still has very good
pieces oh no it's not one of those well
I have a passed pawn let's just push it
I create some weaknesses when I do that
these these two can certainly come under
some heavy fire under two for black
what am i doing on this you just
exchanged Queens Bishop b5 centralized
I gotta go a bit fast so I think I like
this idea
and also that I could pivot here so
let's get my bishop out of the line of
fire first of all try and be irritating
with these bishops so
see
you
where's this guy going
this night could be pretty pesky here
here here looking at these squares maybe
even here is checks available here the
nights
pen
one reason I didn't want to go here
because I felt that h6 is almost always
desirable
King
a reason to have maybe gone to g5 is
that it has a the idea to quickly
transfer towards the queenside if I need
it here it's pretty much kingside
committed
so
he squares the bishops around and go
forward
into the pin surprising
preparing this
you
yeah there's
and pressure here
maybe I have to go here
pairing to meet the doubling in the
rooks with c4
here this if I play see for there's a
six
published at least a little bit with my
bishop move getting out of the threat
and now there's still this pin to
resolve
I have this move at some
if there's this doubling up c4 oh maybe
I end up just losing this upon hikes
yeah here here
to play this
think so
taketake here and this is the one that
concerns me piling up and see for what
do I do
have that yeah okay there's a way to to
kick the majors off of this under ten
seconds
right there
okay interesting move
so this is one idea
another
hmm and also stops this
if I go here and
years of annoying
sure
to do this Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes
Bishop takes pawn
I have Bishop takes pawn
here if Knight f4 I could back up
think I'm gonna give this a go
it's not easy this pressure
okay
yep it's
detected
okay
yeah
you
I think I take with the king
you
even material at this stage
hmm I have to go here
here to have this kind of
idea available huh they opened up there
seventh-ranked
here here you can't take twice because
at the end there's a check and I'm on
the c5 square
stopping the knife from getting that f4i
could be a transfer targeting this
I have to go here yikes
I think they should focus on f3 now you
know
here here okay
you
I'm asking for some trouble with
I need to scoot on over
yeah they're setting that up
okay think I want to neutralize
five
[Music]
Wow
okay
I'm thinking I want to push actually
yeah
at the end
minor piece
oh I'm on the rook try take this
can still take here because they're on
my ruck yeah
next moves important
right here if I take there's rook a
three my a pawn Falls
objectively I think this should be a
draw but this night is tricky
I think I'm in a meeting that so maybe I
should keep these pieces away from my
King so I don't get forked
endgame
I'll take here I'm stopping
[Music]
stopping night F for might get checked
around for a little bit
I'd have to go to the edge
want to control this night hmm could
bring the bishop back
you
Oh
going into a pen maybe maybe it's okay
to repeat
I'll go into
pin
just for a moment I could I don't cares
that
want to get out of the pen now
bo
cut the king out first
King f3
Kings should be able to talk
I'd have for King f3 my bishops ready to
be on a good square my rook is on a good
square cutting the king of Lena for King
f3 Brooks III King here I could maybe
even do this knight normally on this
after Foursquare is very good okay
no night f4 nice move
okay I gotta go
here maybe
why here actually why not here defending
the pond
yeah so that's her
Banwari where I went I messed up there
ah that was that was very foolish
take the night
I guess try and give this a go now I'm
just trying to hold a draw King F 1
instead of King G 1
I was silly
both our kings are cut off
for black
pants these pawns I somehow
shouldn't move my pawn because I want to
have this resource available to bail out
for a draw yeah so I think I have to
just sit here
yeah I think this is very important
detail
and if the King comes over here at
see ya
I could deal with one pun as if this
pond gets rolling so here I have this
they should make now King move here I
have this
King move here I have this and then
maybe I could take pawns with check yeah
we'll go I don't know
now maybe here
waiting possibly a rook check defending
here I want I want to maybe pick this
pawn up somehow some variation
the rook has to go
think now is my time to
towards my rook
here
here check and then here
I have I think I have to I probably
didn't shouldn't have
not too long I'm out
one
check here if this
I can take
oh now that's pushing through
I think he's pushing through
to come over with my own
here here takes there's a check
take my palm now
what a difference that King move
ya know this is completely lost
fortunate
timing
you
okay
you
I guess here
checking distance
you
he's gonna hide right here
you
I'll play it out
you
anyways to do it step up
and then weasel around
and I'm really regretting mind
decision to go king g1 and King f1
instead King g1 there's no reason I was
backing up no matter what
you
okay
you
yeah and there are no stalemate tricks
we'll just play it out to me
Oh
That's not me yeah okay
Jiji
before I look at it with the engine
look at this this position right here
yes one
nice move
often and after if Knight f4 was played
with the King cut off felt like I can
maybe even do something at some point
with my King and Bishop against their
king
but knight f6 was nice
and kingi one
and I don't know
- this pawn here here
to g3 there's no mating that's against
my king I'll have a look at it with the
ending even if
[Music]
even though I lost that pawn I want to
see if there was a way to draw it so
opening wise this is noted as the
Stockholm variation now let me do a an
engine evaluation somebody already
clicked on it we'll see where we stand
with that
okay Knight takes pawn takes
hmm you know this did seem a little bit
weird Bishop g7
so other moves try to hang on to the
palm
that was what I was familiar with seeing
Bishop g7
I scooped up the pond
III II for
those two
castles huh oh so neat okay one of the
moves well queen c4 is what I played
between a a3
threatens this oh right and considering
what happened in the game this idea with
cui 95
oh I could go here pressure on this and
then take here with my bishop that is a
nice improvement
so let's say Knight f6 Bishop takes c4
be six here and I'm not hmm I like this
mover a lot queen a3 how much time did I
spend on that one only 15 seconds
huh
yeah I I didn't I didn't appreciate how
fast that Queen a5 move hits but this is
this would
would make things a bit more smooth than
this it's not an advantage for me or
anything but
I'm able to have a structure that
I enjoy much more I'm able to recapture
on d4 if it comes under fire and not
fear Queen a5 okay nice nice thing to
know right there queen a3 on this move
ten
took with the Queen
Misha be too
and best is to take with the pawn right
now
have to take with the epon or the night
it says
okay yeah I didn't I didn't even give
any uh any any thought to taking with
the night that's better
Knight takes I have this isolated pawn
see they're an isolated pawn or hanging
pawns I went with the hanging pawns
likes Knight b6 b6 in the game
okay where does it where is it looking
what is it looking like with the graph
it's still crunching the numbers
inaccuracies mistakes blunders for each
still still thinking should be done
graph is complete
for inaccuracy
mistakes three blunders by me three and
accuracy zero zero for my opponent okay
yeah so this was a I guess okay the
mistake that might her inaccuracy I
guess
fresh real quick is the graph done yeah
it is official the graph is done yeah
this is the full graph because at some
point black was completely winning
so it's only considered an inaccuracy I
guess this this move here Queens c8 or
is it that's not even considering that
any inaccuracy surprising
okay blenders upon might have six is
better I do this
this
I'm in trouble
but I could take right away
and it's not easy oh you know I didn't
even consider coming coming back along
this diagonal why not it's not
suggesting I do that
yeah I guess this is still the the
correct way to do it take away some
squares from the rooks okay
Queens Bishop b5 up upon but it's tricky
turkey 7c4 suggested I didn't like c4
because of here and then
[Music]
I have ruined Bishop to b3 now I was
thinking maybe even this first and then
isn't my bishop gonna be kicked now I
guess I could throw some punches at the
rooks first I like this decision black
made and what I felt was a tough spot
for black position wise and even on the
clock right around this stage I mean
they're under a minute I had three
minutes
so I went Bishop here and now it's an
blacks favor what should I have done
here see ya so c4
see four right here yeah because in the
game if I if I went like this
right now there's a reply to take the
pawn
but here here there's no pressure on the
pond just yet and I could now that
there's no pin here I could start
harassing the rooks some with my bishops
interesting detail so c4
hmm okay
c4 now Knight age five is strong yeah
strong move rook f d1
takes pawn takes and we enter this
we're his
materialise should be a draw
maybe it's coming right down to that
that decision with King f1 is to the
king g1 rook e8 is even there oh oh oh
oh oh I could go check and then here
possibly yeah yeah check here there's
this and if check here check block yeah
this should be yeah I draw I'd have an
easier time in that ending with the
superior minor piece but I don't think
that that would be enough and they
should be equal yeah very quickly
regretted my decision here is this just
losing no not quite losing but I have to
be super accurate now because I went to
f1
what was my
where was my head at during that moment
that I really think it was worthwhile to
come over in this direction I wasn't
thinking about going to light square
opposite the night or anything like that
I mean I should I should just be going
here or I watched these two points in my
Bishop's free
to go over it wherever it wants next
I had it in my mind that I could just go
here next and it's okay that the rook is
there because my bishop would be
defending up but Knight to g4 is hitting
both so if I go King here h5 what would
I be doing
I would probably push my pawn I could
maybe end up in some trouble with these
pawns inching down these two I don't
have any fear early but add a pawn to
the mix some mating that's possibly
anyhow this is what I would be shooting
for
King keep
cutoff apparently a draw okay let's have
a look at this ending where I do in fact
lose the pawn
and is it still drawable it is a form is
now at this point I was saying here is
not a good idea because I want to have
this idea is this losing it is losing no
it just said - - for a second
anyhow I feel that it is important so
let's let's go with what I did in the
game king g1 and what am i doing King f1
king h1 I don't know if I'll really be
able to make much sense of which one is
better
hmm King here and still draw what was
the right here right here I have a draw
with the move oh I could I could go
hunting for this pond like this now that
they're separated
I had it in my mind I wanted to go here
for some reason or oh no no no I I had
in my mind that I only go to a5 after
the pawn has moved
but rook somewhere
off of the a file
can track this pond down right
rooks III rock here here and it would be
a drawn ending
ah okay is this just the losing move now
h5 yeah I'm not gonna be there in time
h4 this is the issue right here I
thought that this would save me but it
doesn't because of h3 just in case I
wasn't able to express it during the
game each three not h2 um although I
guess this is still this is still
winning for black but cleanest is the
check and I cannot go here to guard this
square so first the check it then the
push and black is pushing through
yeah I needed to go so in a future games
I'm just making mental notes to myself
here future games once there's these two
ranks between the pawns this is another
opportunity for me to abandon this pawn
and just go hunting after the Jeep on
how much time did I have right around
this stage hmm we're both under a minute
we've been under a minute for a while in
this one in from here I guess it is now
just losing throughout I don't see any
tricks for me black
fine they're advancing that pond nice
pocket for the king and straight to me
with this one okay
well as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video I didn't even
realize my opponent played this for me I
was thinking this that's that was a cool
end g2 for me okay
as usual feel free to leave any feedback
to this one in the comment section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two why that's all for now take
care bye
you